[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Merhaba Hoş geldiniz
gerçi tanıtıldım ama konuşma metninde
biraz kendimi tanıtıyordum Onun için
Müsadenizle orayı hızlı geçerek
anlatacağım Oğuz Okay 35 yıllık bir
beyaz yakalayayım aynı zamanda
seyahat etmeyi
Kent kültürü üzerine yazılar yazmayı
insan hikayeleri mekan hikayeleri
kovalamayı seven biriyim sevmekte de
kalmayıp bunu
klasik medyada
radyoda ve kendi programımda ve
Instagram
sayfamda ilgililerle paylaşıyorum Bir de
bu coğrafyaya ait yazılmış bir kitabın
yazarıyım
Burası benim için çok önemli Şu kırmızı
çember sözüm vardı tedx konuşması
yaparsam bir adamı dışarı Atacağım
biliyorum çünkü bu kural dışı Ama bu
akşam hepinizden kuralları yıkmanızı
zorlamanızı istiyorum Çünkü hayat bizim
için değişimi şart kılıyor
konuşmaya başlamadan önce bir küçük
teşekkürü de Bugün bizim bir dediğimizi
iki etmeyen genç dostlarımız genç
öğrenciler için yapmak istiyorum ve
onlara şunu söylemek istiyorum
muhteşem bir coğrafyada muhteşem bir
gençlik yaşıyorsunuz çünkü sizin
gençliğiniz o kadar güzel mayalanıyor ki
bu coğrafyada Bunun kıymetini önemini
önünüzdeki
5-10-20-30-40-50 yılda göreceksiniz
nereden mi Biliyorum Çocukluğum bu
coğrafyada geçti o delikanlılığın bu
coğrafyada geçti ilk defa bu coğrafyada
aşık oldum ilk defa bu coğrafyada tarihi
öğrendim ilk defa bu coğrafyada
heyecanla
yazılanları çizilenleri Okumayı Öğrendim
Dolayısıyla bu coğrafyada yetişiyor
olmanın lütfen kıymetini bilin ve bir
kez daha ev sahipliğiniz için size ve
değerli öğretmenlerimize çok teşekkür
ediyorum
Şimdi artık Yavaş Yavaş konuşmaya da
geçebiliriz
konuşmanın akışında biraz Değişiklik
yapmam gerekti Çünkü aslında interaktif
bir konuşma yapmayı planlıyordum hatta
internet üzerinden Instagram üzerinden
katılımınızı sağlayacak bir Kurgun vardı
ama maalesef
internet olmaması sebebiyle bunu
yapamadık ama problem değil yıkıldık
ayağa kalkacağız çözümümüz var
İnsanlık tarihi için çok önemli iki
insanın sözüyle geldim bu akşam buraya
o iki söz adeta bu akşamki konuşmama yön
verdi bunlardan bir tanesi
ünlü mikrobiyolog ve Kimyager
Pastör diyor ki
şans
yalnızca hazır beyinleri seçer lütfen
not edelim cebimize koyalım Çünkü
konuşma sırasında sık sık geçecek ikinci
söz ise ünlü düşünür sokratese ait
Sokrates diyor ki
eşinizi doğru seçerseniz Mutlu
yanlış seçerseniz Filozofu olursunuz
yalnız evli olanlar açısından bir
sıkıntı olmaması adına buradaki eş
seçeneğini lütfen iş ve meslek olarak
okuyun yani
sokratesin sözünü düzeltelim işinizi
Mesleğinizi doğru seçerseniz Mutlu
yalnız yanlış seçerseniz de benim gibi
birisi olursunuz Onun da hikayesini
şimdi anlatacağım sizlere
[Müzik]
fark ettiyseniz bu iki söz Aslında
birbirinden çok bağımsız gibi eğer
salonunun ışıkları açık olsaydı veya
Instagram üzerinden etkileşimimiz mümkün
olsaydı size şunu soracaktım siz
bu iki sözden
hangisine kendinizi daha yakın
hissediyorsunuz
eşlediğinizi duyuyorum ama konu eş değil
iş olsun lütfen beni de oraya zorlamayın
o konuda konuşmam mümkün değil
biz
soru sizi bir tercihe yöneltti değil mi
bir şeye karar vermeniz gerekiyor Acaba
hiç düşündünüz mü
Yetişkin bir insan günde kaç kere kaç
bin kere karar almak zorunda farkındayım
zor bir soru ama bu zor sorunun cevabını
bizim için
Robert West ile Enstitüsü yönetim ve
liderlik araştırması profesörü Dr Joel
homans 2015 yılında cevaplamış ne diyor
biliyor musunuz
Yetişkin bir insan
ortalama günde
35 bin karar veriyor
35.000 karar yılda ne yapar
12.712 milyon 775 bin karar yapar
Bu kararlar nasıl kararlar bunların
içerisinde
Sabah kaçta kalkacağınız var
yemek Akşama ne yemek yapacağınız var
veya Daha önemlisi kiminle flört
edeceğiniz kiminle evleneceğiniz hangi
işi seçeceğiniz gibi önemli kararlar da
var
şimdi sormak istiyorum salonda
her gün verdiğim 35.000 kararın 35 bini
de doğrudur isabetlidir diyen bir
babayiğit var mı
kimseyi görmüyorum ama elinde kalktığını
zannetmiyorum Bu mümkün değil bu mümkün
değil
Bunun dışında
hayatımızı direk etkileyen ve ülkemizin
çalışan nüfusunun
%87'si tarafından yanlış verilen bir
karar ve sonuçlarını konuşalım
bugün Hayır eş seçimi değil Lütfen oraya
takılmayın O bir örnekti ve biz o örneği
eşi işle değiştirdik Ya beni yanlış bir
yere yönlendireceksiniz ve avukatsınız
diye endişe ediyorum yapmayın
şimdi o yüzde 87'lik kesimden birisi de
benim o %87 Neyi yanlış seçmiş dedik iş
seçimini Meslek seçimini yanlış yapmış
kişiler
35 yıl önce iş hayatında meslek seçerken
Şunlara baktım
Daha doğrusu nelere bakmadığımı
söyleyeyim istiyorsanız ilk önce
nelerden keyif alıyorum
nelere yetenekliyim
nelerde kendimi gösterebilirim nelerde
başarılıyım bunlara bakmadım iki şeye
baktım bir
gelecekte çok parayı nasıl kazanırım
statüyü nasıl kazanırım
ve Meslek seçimini böyle yaptım
açıkçası bugün geldiğim noktaya
baktığımda
bu seçimi yaparken ki kriterlerimle
belli bir noktaya geldiğimi görüyorum
çünkü
yabancı bir şeylikte
yönetici olarak çalışıyorum
belli bir tatminim de var fakat
Bunu yaparken çok çok öncelere
gittiğimde yani o 35 sene öncesine 30
sene öncesine gittiğimde ilk yıllarda
Şunu fark ettim
Hiç huzurum yok
daha çalışıyorum deli gibi iş yapıyorum
para kazanıyorum yükseliyim bekarım ya
dışarıda her gece dolaşıyorum falan ama
olmuyor işte yolunda gitmeyen bir şey
var
o zaman şuna karar verdim Demek ki o gün
Meslek seçiminde bir hata yapmışım
ve bu hatadan
Allah'tan bu hatadan erken dönebilmeyi
nasıl dönebileceğimi
o gün gittiğim bir profesyonel
şirkette girdiğim
testle gördüm çünkü
yaptığım iş ile
heyecanım duygularım yeteneklerim Gece
ile gündüz gibi farklıydı Ben gündüzü
görmek istiyorum Bu taraf gece bu
taraftayım
geceyi yaşamak istiyorum Bu taraf gündüz
o zaman bir değişiklik yapmak
gerektiğine karar verdim ama
değişikliğin ne olduğunu da hala
bilmiyorum Bir taraftan da işi
sürdürüyorum
bu şartlar altında iş hayatının 6 7
yılında yurt dışından bir iş teklifi
aldım hikaye bundan sonra başlıyor biraz
uzaklığının farkındayım ama hikaye
burada başlıyor yurt dışından bir iş
teklifi aldım Ee ne güzel işte yurt
dışına gidiyorsun bugün birçok insanın
istediği şey bu diyeceksiniz eminim veya
içinden öyle geçiriyorsunuz ama Kazın
ayağı öyle değil iş teklif eden şirket
Suudi Arabistan'da bir şirket
ve takdir edersiniz ki burada gördüğüm
öğrendiğim alıştığım hayat tarzından
bambaşka bir hayat tarzına gidiyorum
bindim uçağa cebimde pasaportum
kafamda ön yargılarım ve umutlarımla
Suudi Arabistan'a gittim ilk 3-4 sene
felaket kötü geçti ilk 3-4 ay felaket
kötü geçti geceleri uyuyamıyorum
bir kanal var açıyorum zaten
seyredemiyorum kendimi sokağa atıyorum
7/24 açık marketler var oralarda
dolaşıyorum yani Düşünsenize uykusuz bir
adam Market dolaşıyor 7/24 dedim ki bu
böyle olmaz bir şey yapmam lazım ve o an
ne yapmam gerektiğini buldum bir kendime
bir uğraş bulmalıyım 2 Bu uğraşımla
sadece vakit geçirmemeliyim bir farklı
kültürlerden insanlarla da tanışmalıyım
dedim balık adamı olmaya karar verdim
Bir İngiliz su altı topluluğuna
başvurdum işte eğitimleri aldım falan ve
onlarla dalmaya başladım
hatırlayalım ne demişti bu istasyon
şans hazır beyinleri seçer Çünkü ben
beynimi hazırlamıştım hayatımı
değiştirmek istiyordum ve pastörün
Sözünü böyle Böylece doğrulamış olduk
kendimi çok üzdüm
kendimi batık dalışlarına
kitap okumaya
kızıldeniz'in o muhteşem güzelliklerine
ve seyahat etmeye adadım
İngilizlerle sık sık seyahat ediyorum
İngiliz dostlarımla bir yerlere
gidiyorum dalışlar yapıyorum
Sizler Kaşif ruhlu ulusudur ve
kendilerini
kızgın güneşin altında
kudurmuş köpekler ve İngilizler dolaşır
dolaşır
deyimiyle tanımlarlar Dolayısıyla bu
adamlarla seyahat ettiğiniz zaman ki
Yani o şansı yakaladım
keşif ruhuyla seyahat etmesini
öğreniyorsunuz Dolayısıyla bu keşif
ruhuyla ve İngiliz dostlarımla yollara
düştük birçok şehri ülkeyi gezdik ve bu
arada hem seyahat ediyorum hem de o
yaşadıklarımı ilerleyen günlerde bu
günlerde böyle hafıza ağırlaşınca yaşa
bağlı olarak hatırlayabilmek için
defterime notlar şeklinde alıyorum kendi
kendine çalışan bir sistem bir şeyler
biriktiriyorum hiç unutmuyorum
kenya'dayız
nairobiden mambaaza'ya Trenle gidiyoruz
karşımda çok güzel çekici bir İngiliz
kadın oturuyor ama sürekli yazı yazıyor
takdir edersiniz ki gencin bekarım gözüm
hanımefendinin üzerinde dayanamadım
dedim ki siz ne yapıyorsunuz Allah
aşkına ben dedi freelance seyahat
yazarıyım ilk defa duyuyorum bu lafı
zaten bakışlarımdan da hanımefendi
anlamış
anlatmaya başladı freelance seyahat
yazarlığı nedir biraz ağır anlıyorum
seyahat 12 saatte 12 saat boyunca
anlattı bu kadıncağız Bana ama o kadar
iyi anlattı ki o gün not defterime Hadi
artık sen de yaz
diye not düştüm ve bugün hala o Not
Defteri
şimdi seyahatler bir taraftan devam
ediyor O sırada elime Türkiye'den gelen
bir dergi geçti dergide bir reklam var
reklamda şu
sağdun Bora'nın kendisi
yelkenli tekneyle dünyayı dolaşan ilk
türk'tür
Kısmetin dünya turu adlı kitabının
reklamı var
kitabı edinmek istedim işte reklamı
veren kitap evine bir faks yazdım
aylarca faksla cevap gelmedi faksı
yazdığımı unuttum bir gün bir paket
geldi İçinden bir kitap ve bir kart
çıktı
faksı yazdığım Kitap Evi karta şunu
yazmıştı Sevgili dostum keyifli oku
Parası önemli değil İstanbul'a
geldiğinde tanışırız o zaman ödeşiriz
diye yazmıştı
İstanbul'a döndüğümde kitabı yollayan
ismini anacağım Burada da denizler
kitabevinin sahibi Turgay Erol namı
diğer
kaptanla karşılaştık sohbetlere başladık
sohbetler ardı ardına geldi falan Turgay
Şunu fark etti
Ya dostum dedi sende dedi inanılmaz
seyahat Tutkusu var ve
dalış merakı var tarih merakı var Sen
dedi sıkı durun Çanakkale savaşlarıyla
alakalı kitaplar toplamaya başladı dedi
göreceksin dedi sana yeni ufuklar açacak
Gerçekten de öyle oldu bu arada
Çanakkale'ye gelip gidiyorum batık
dalışları yapıyorum o güne kadar ismini
duymadım bir
Dünya Savaşı Batı Osmanlı harp gemisinin
ismini duydum Mesudiye Zırhlısı
duruş O duyuş biraz araştırdım O biraz
araştırma 4 yıl sürdü
İngiltere başta Türkiye olmak üzere
İngiltere İtalya Avustralya ve Amerika
Birleşik Devletleri Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri dışındaki tüm arşivlere
fiilen giderek çalıştım 4 yıl ve onun
sonunda 4 yılın sonunda 2005 yılında
Efendi Kaptan kurtar bizi
Mesudiye Zırhlısı
1874-1914 adlı kitabım çıktı şimdi kitap
çok sattı mı Hayır satmadı ama
çok spesifik bir konudaydı Bu konuyla
ilgilenen kişiler arasında ses getirdi
ve kişilere ses getiren kişiler kadar
ses getiren başka bir noktada dergiler
oldu tarih dergileri benden yazılar
istemeye başladı ve ben
tarih dergilerine yazılar yazmaya
başladın düşünebiliyor musunuz nereden
nereye o trende İngiliz çekici kadına
bakan ve seyahat etme
freelance seyahat yazarlarının ne
olduğunu bilmeyen adam 3-5 sene sonra
Türkiye'deki tarih dergilerine ve
seyahat dergilerine yazılar yazmaya
başladı hatırlayalım ne demişti ünlü
düşünür Sokrates Hayır eş değil işinizi
doğru seçin işinizi doğru seçemezseniz
Seyyah olursunuz Gezgin olursunuz işte
Sokrates yıllar sonra haklı çıkmıştı
Suudi Arabistan defterini kapatınca
Türkiye'ye döndüm
[Müzik]
Türkiye'nin önde gelen en büyük Hava
Yolları şirketlerinden bir tanesi de
yönetici olarak işe başladım
hala tutkuyla seyahat ediyorum geziyorum
tozuyorum fakat
bir hayalim var
o hayalimde şu; bu sürede hiç hayal
kurmayı bırakmadım bir radyo programı
yapacağım nereden geldiyse aklıma Derya
Deniz bakın ismi de hazır programın
akışları hazır her şeye akış derya deniz
nasıl yaparız nasıl ederiz falan o
sırada yazdığım dergilerde Doğuş
grubundaki dergiler
editörümle konuştum
Doğuş grubunda radyoların başındaki
sevgili Ahmet Yeşiltepe ile beni
görüştürdü ve ben
şirketten mesai arkadaşım Rauf gerzle bu
NTV'de havacılık
Deniz ve tarih değil ama havacılık
programı yapmaya başladım
hatırlayalım ne demişti
bir taraftan radyo programları bir
taraftan dergi yazıları devam ediyor ama
o sırada çalıştığım hava yolu şirketinde
ciddi bir kriz yaşandı Uluslararası bir
kriz yaşandı ve çıkış yolu olarak kendi
denetçilerini yetiştirme
prensibi belirlendi ve o kişilerden bir
tanesi de uluslararası hava taşırmacılar
birliğinin dünyadaki hayatının dünyadaki
250 denekçisinden biri olacaktı gönüllü
oldum gittim Yunanistan'da eğitim aldım
ve Yunanistan'a giderken
Atlas dergisinin Atlas tarih dergisine
dedim ki bakın Ben Yunanistan'a
gidiyorum
Yunanlıların Osmanlı'ya karşı isyanı
başlattıkları kalavrita kasabasına çok
yakınım oraya gideyim sizin için bir
yazı yazayım dedim ikna oldular gittim
yazıyı yazdım yazıyı getirdiğim gün
editörün önüne koyduğumda sevgili Kansu
şarmanın
suratını bugün gibi hatırlarım
kıpkırmızı bir surat
böyle
dikleşmiş saçlar Ya arkadaş dedi Biz
seni dedi Yunanistan'a tarih yazısı yaz
diye yolladık tarih dergisi yaz diye
yolladık ama Sen bambaşka bir seyahat
yazısı yazmışsın dedi
kızmıştı belli ama sonra döndü dedi ki
çok da iyi yazmışsın dedi o gündür
bugündür sadece seyahat yazısı yazıyorum
Bu arada Yunanistan'daki eğitimi
tamamladıktan sonra dedim yani fırsat
fırsatı kovalıyor
denetçiliğe başladım
birçok egzotik ülkeye gittim bu fırsatlı
ve başkasının parasıyla gittim güzel
olan bu
sonra
2019 yılında NTV radyoda program
yaptığımız ortam bir gün aradı dedi ki o
bana moruk derdi moruk dedi kafa
radyodan dedi program teklifi var
yapalım mı yapalım dedim hiç tereddütsüz
yani
aktüel programdı fakat bir şey oldu
Rauf çılgın bir adamdı motorla dünya
turları yapardı Avrupa'yı dolaşırdı ve
İstanbul'da e-5'te
en sol şeritten en sağ şeritte geçen bir
katil sürücü tarafından çarpılarak
öldürüldü ve ben o gün programı bıraktım
tabi çok acı Yani yıkıldım şimdi bunun
devamında ayağa kalkmayı da anlatacağım
yıkıldım
sevgili
Nihat Sırdar ve güçlü metre dedi ki abi
burası senin radyon
istediğin kadar rahat et İstediğin kadar
düşün kafanı topla gel Burada istediğin
zamanda program yap dedim ki ben artık
program yapamam dediler ki bir dakika ya
gezmek yetmesi niye Radyo ya
taşımıyorsun hop Talih geldi bizi
radyoda gezmek yetmeze yolladı Ondan
sonra pandemi başladı
pandemide ne yapacağız Hiçbir bu arada
seyahat acentaları ve rehberler
eşliğinde Eskiden sadece kendim için
yaptığım turları Takipçilerim için
yapmaya başladım Biz acenta'mız
Rehberimiz böyle her hafta sonu 40 kişi
50 kişi İstanbul'u dolaşmaya başladık bu
da başka bir açılım oldu bizim için
işte radyo programı bu derken
pandemi patladı pandemi de herkes gibi
ben de eve kapandım gene bir yıkılma
hikayesi ve ne oldu Hemen dedik ki
online konferanslara başlayalım yeme
içme hikayeleri
gayet iyi gitti pandemi bittikten sonra
da
Usta uluslararası servise lezzet
akademisiyle o Online'da yaptığımız
atölyeleri gerçek hayata taşıdık
muhteşem mutfaklarda muhteşem işler
yapmaya başladık hatırlayalım ne
demiştir
Talih hazır beyinleri seçer Bu da böyle
bir talihle gelinen bir nokta oldu işte
Dostlar Benim Hikayem bu
Umarım Sizler de hayatta düştüğünüzde
kalktığınızda yanlış kararlar
verdiğinizde
kendinizi dinlersiniz size yüksek
motivasyon sağlayacak tatmin sağlayacak
sizi mutlu edecek işleri yaparsınız ve
böylece O hayatın hoyratlığına ayağa
kalkarak dur dersiniz Hazır mısınız
[Alkış]